this episode is brought to you by
curiosity stream a subscription
streaming service that offers thousands
of documentaries and non-fiction titles
for some of the world's best filmmakers
including exclusive originals for
instance there's amazing gravity hd
where we can see all batch einstein's
theories of special and general
relativity to show how the rate
at which you age is affected by gravity
and the speed at which you move about in
your daily life get a limited axis
starting in just 2.99 a month for
19.99 a year and for our audience the
first 30 days are completely
free if you sign up at
curiositystream.com
chess and use the promo code the chess
during
the sign-up process possibly
okay uh syrian 77
uh apparently from syria
glad to see uh people playing chess in
syria
wow is this a gambit or is this a mouse
slip
i think it's a mouth slip
if it is a gambit kudos to you because
not many people will would dare to do
that
that's the one thing like i never
criticize people here
for here it's just
playing your aggressively uh playing
aggressively and just
giving it your your best shot
yeah [ __ ] before
like you could make the case uh here
that
the g pawn is not the worst pawn to lose
so we have some
compensation um probably i will not
castle
anytime soon though and that's going to
make it
a bit more uh difficult for for white to
attack
another thing that's good for me is that
without the g-pawn
um it's hard to get h5 h4h5 going
seeing us um okay now i'm actually going
to give him
potentially h4h5 but um
or should i now go 97. my first
intention was just to uh
which is to take on f3 uh
[Music]
actually c6 was probably more precise it
does have the
it does have a shaft here with uh um
with knight d5 if not takes d5 rook
takes
g4 i can go knight f6
maybe rook h4 doesn't look good though
he moves his rook away then i take f4
and
i'm doing great positionally speaking
i have to stress though that i didn't
see 95 so
97 was
it was a blunder i think i can be
yeah i think that artists uh 95
is logical the only problem is that he
just moved
his um
he just moved this queen from from um
from d1 uh to d2 so basically
he could have gotten this position uh
with monitoring f6
with uh with himself to um
to move and now he's just um
um yeah he's just lost a lot of tempo
there
basically uh yeah castle seems normal
i think i'll take enough
[Music]
on f4 and go e6
with a very solid pawn structure
it should be noted that if
knight xd7 i probably will take back
with the
king not to allow some f5 shenanigans
i do have a check there but i don't
really like taking back with the g
pawn so i would have probably taken
um take him with um
the king there in order to
[Music]
stay as solid as possible and with such
a rock-solid palm structure
my king is usually going to be very safe
in the
in the in the center my opponent has
done decently well
here um after palm blunder
early on actually now that i think of it
uh castle's queen side was pretty pretty
awful
my part since he i allowed him not a
forfeit by rook b3 with potentially some
serious kind of play
so that was just very very sloppy on my
part and
gave him um an avenue to to get back in
the game
now knight b6 obviously that was uh in
order to
to prevent those uh kinds of shenanigans
the algos rook c8 and um
and uh and c5 and uh
try to be
be better on both sides
once again structure ass has been in
has been the theme in many games today
pawn structure is it's
very solid it's very good um
you know what let's go fishing for some
puns over here
rook c3 uh
are there are there any tactics i feel
like there may be
i'm just going to take a pawn for the
moment
pawn grabber that i am okay uh he ran
out of time
now rating is 5 000. amazing
amazing